you know there are some scientists who
they sort of get into science
accidentally they think they you know
they met somebody here they saw somebody
or whatever their story is in my case I
can't ever remember not wanting to be a
scientist okay I think I briefly flirted
with the idea of driving a locomotive
train I would have was probably two or
three I was very fortunate to come from
a family that was very focused on
education my father was a doctor in a
small town but education and especially
science and medicine were an important
part of the sort of family culture and
so I also grew up in the United States
of America i was born in nineteen fifty
the significance of that was that after
World War two America was really at that
time seen it was becoming it already was
a very powerful country it was taking on
global responsibilities including
scientific research but also in a major
competition with the Soviet Union as
everybody knows of the so-called Cold
War and when the Soviets developed the
nuclear bomb and when they also were the
first to put satellites into space quite
frankly it scared the lamb out of
certainly Americans but certainly a lot
of the world and so it caused an energy
and the whole enterprise of scientific
research especially the physical
sciences but also biomedical sciences
got energized and so that's the
environment I grew up in and in that
environment scientists and medical
doctors doing research and so on we're
really prized by society and I'm not
entirely sure that's so true today but
it was certainly true then and we were
seen as assets very little in the
liability call and so you know as a
young boy your hero might have been a
base
player but it might also have been a
physicist like like Oppenheimer or
Einstein